good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation and this is the
umpteenth in this series of seminars
about long term thinking I'm gonna
basically just outline the evening a
little bit and then George station is
going to introduce his father Freeman
and Freeman will speak for a bit on the
subject of the difficulty of looking far
ahead and then his family and me I get
to be a cousin I guess with evening and
we'll talk for the rest of our time
tonight it's not talking in Q&A it's
going to be talk and Q&A so be funneling
questions out to the volunteers and
yellow hats they'll pass them up to
Kevin Kelly and Alexander Rose will be
picking out the most servic and poignant
ones and passing them up to me and all I
had to read them or hand them around to
the other family members this is an
historic occasion this is the first time
these three Dyson's have been on one
stage together and not the last at all
so let me introduce George Dyson who's
already spoken here before wonderfully
on basically the digital past and future
and he's here to show us some pictures
it's great to be back and with Esther we
were actually scheduled to do this a
year ago and Esther's plane got canceled
in Dallas which allowed Tim O'Reilly to
say that Esther was stuck in Texas like
our government and so my family my
parents Oh Stuart a tremendous debt of
gratitude because I was a teenager in
New Jersey getting into all kinds of
trouble things look really bad and then
one day my older sister not que estaba
older sister who lived in Menlo Park
sent this envelope that had the first
prototype version of the Colle Earth
Catalog and that's largely it reviewed
this book on kayaks and that's really
what inspired me to get out of the house
and head west so here we we are 1955
picked a picture taken by my mother in
Berkeley so we're back you know 50 years
later three know who's in the front
front rollin on that side and I'm
getting introduced Freeman you Esther
and I need no introduction but Freeman
so he started out very young and this is
Freeman's
but this is actually his most important
scientific paper it's it's I'm going to
make a serious point this is 1929 so
Freeman is five and a half and the
important thing about this is that it's
wrong and that shows that you he wasn't
like most five-year-olds Woodcock where
Dodie encyclopedia incopy the chapter on
planets but he was figuring it out for
himself from the very beginning and he's
done that with his whole life he's
always not taking the accepted wisdom
but but question did so a 27th July 1929
age five and a half then he started
writing science fiction so this is age
between age eight and nine 1932 33 so
this is a science fiction story about
what could have been the end of the
world it's an asteroid
so the asteroid eros is going to hit the
moon and again it's all done with
numbers there's lots of calculations
that's the way Freeman always looked at
things and then later this became real
he actually you know not many years
later in the sort of time scale we are
now he was at working for general atomic
on real spaceships and and crazy schemes
project Orion which was the plan to
launch ship bigger than this auditorium
propelled with bombs he became one of
the leaders of the project so he got to
play the role that he'd written about in
that book things like this plan to go to
the satellites of the outer planets so
this is the the predictions that that
fell flat we didn't do that we got there
with the little Voyager probes but not
not with any people yet thinking big
this is super Orion the launched mass of
eight million tons so that's something
like the size of San Francisco
and here looking even farther the very
high velocity ships that could cross the
solar system in a month and here Freeman
is changing from being a physicist to
being an engineer he says 10,000
kilometers per second in principle
actually he said easily but crossed it
out so that's that that's that's the
difference between physics and
engineering and
and and part of what Freeman has done so
well as gold is go back and forth across
that boundary during his life so here
1958 they actually are testing that the
prototype of this arrived so he actually
did some hands-on stuff this is the
launching of this is using c4 high
explosive they were allowed the
physicists were allowed 400 pounds
without adult supervision if they got
from the Navy so those were different
times and now we now Freeman can't fly
with a Swiss Army knife but then they
could so we're not making progress also
invented the something that did work
this is the treeger nuclear reactor
which is still the most successful
nuclear reactor in circulation there
were 65 or 70 of them built I think 60
are still operating it was profitable
from the word go still profitable today
Ted Taylor and here the only case you'll
find this is actually a study on weapons
of mass destruction that quotes
Wordsworth very appropriate for long now
the unimaginable touch of time this is
actually very interesting study on
unreal I mean we're talking weapons of
real mass destruction and for they've
been involved in lots of long-term
public policy establishing the nuclear
test-ban the hearings which again well
we're looking at from 1977 almost 30
years ago looking at the future of
genetic engineering and a lot of what's
in those congressional hearings is still
still completely applicable now space
colonization comparing the pilgrims to
the warmest of the space colonists and
that's very much the path Varane
Malthusian principles but note that the
signature from one crackpot to another
and serious if you really look at
long-term problems the stability of
matter is one of them is is matter
really stable and you just just give it
you're just getting the executive
summary here which is it's an academic
problem you don't need to worry about
that but but Freeman questions all these
things even a civilian matter than other
work you did was on the weather the
weather the constants of nature are
really constant or not how do we know
and this one of his best papers I'm I'm
gonna ask him about is this time without
end the question that if in a you know I
think this was done for a different
model universe than we have today but if
the universe goes on forever can mind
and intelligence keep going so this is
sort of trying to answer the great
kurtzweil question if we if we download
you know radio wants to be immortal but
can he really be immortal can you be
immortal you know to the to the final
end of the universe and and the answer
at that time was yes I think it might be
different now and then but not to shy
away from human problems bring this many
essays on human nature and his history
and living in the real world of people
and politics which became his still his
if you have to read one of his books
read this one the autobiography he wrote
thirty years ago was very popular this
is a the advertising brochure for the
Fairmont Hotel in Dallas Texas
that that shows you the extent to which
which Freeman has reached the public
audience but his most famous work of
Sciences is the search for artificial
stellar sources of infrared radiation
which became the basis of the Dyson
Sphere the idea that if we just keep
growing if the 1950s go on forever we
will build a shell around the Sun I have
identified the signal it is from the USS
jenolan the federation transport ship
reported missing in this sector
seventy-five years ago
we have entered a massive gravitational
field captain there are no stars or
other stellar bodies listed on our
navigational charts however sensors
indicate the presence of an extremely
strong gravitational source in this
vicinity can you localize the source of
the gravitational field sensors I'm
having difficulty scanning the object it
appears to be approximately 200 million
kilometers in diameter that's nearly as
large as the earth orbit around the Sun
the objects enormous mass is causing a
great deal of gravimetric interference
that might have prevented our sensors
from detecting it before we dropped out
of warp
well after that everything will be an
anti-climax I'm sorry about that anyway
thank you George that was brilliant now
I'd like just to bring us down to
reality a little bit the the real
problem that I see as a scientist is
that science is organized
unpredictability the whole point of
science is in fact to find circumstances
which are as unpredictable as possible
and see what happens
that's our trade so that's not
altogether conducive to long-range
predictions we are probably the least
qualified to make longer and long-range
predictions of anybody nevertheless we
do it so let me just try one or two it's
it's I'm not really thinking long-range
these days my I'm 81 years old so my
horizons are getting a little bit
constricted one question I'd like to
think about is domestication of
biotechnology that's to me very much in
our future but it's not the long-range
future this is only fifty or a hundred
years long enough for me I look at what
happened to computers when phenomen
built his first computer in Princeton he
had absolutely no idea that computers
were ever going to be small and cheap he
thought they would always be big and
huge and expensive they would belong to
big organizations and that the legend is
that the United States government asked
John for Neyman how many computer how
many computers does the United States
need and he said 818
that was the order of magnitude well of
course it turned out totally different
he never imagined computers getting so
small and cheap that ladies would use
them for doing household accounts and
kids would use them for doing homework
and three-year-olds would use them as as
toys now of course our three-year-olds
are as addicted to computers as we are
and that's our fakes for the rest of the
time as far as we can see ahead well you
should look at the way biotechnology is
today it's in the hands of large
corporations and industries and the
public distrusts it for good reason in
the hands of companies like Monsanto
sort of whipping boy for the
environmentalists Monsanto is in fact a
very good company in doing good stuff
but nevertheless they get blamed because
they're big and because they do things
like putting pesticides into crop plants
which you can easily translate into
putting poisons into food and that's
what they do
and it's unfortunate it was also it was
unfortunate that for Neyman used his
computer for designing hydrogen bombs
which also gave his computers a bad
reputation but it can change and I think
it will change and what I foresee is
that biotech is going to go the same way
that computers went it'll become small
and cheap and user-friendly and there's
a whole world out there of people who
are wonderfully devoted gardeners and
animal breeders people who love snakes
and they're all have little kits that
they can actually use at home for
programming genomes and they can just
this will be a new art form as lively as
cinema or
painting or sculpture the world will
change biotech will become creative and
people's feelings about it will change
too so anyway I hope that'll happen it's
up to you to decide for people the
younger than you anyway I think at that
point I have said enough I'd like this
meeting to be a conversation I carefully
didn't prepare a speech so let's get to
get to work wheels we'll all sit up here
and answer your questions thank you
yes there it's your turn to speak just
say something to ask something well I
think I sit surrounded by a brilliant
scientist predicting the future a
brilliant historian understanding the
past and what it means I was trying to
explain to Stuart what I do in this
illustrious company and it's I don't
want to predict the future I want to
affect it and make it happen
so my my interest in the future is
looking far enough ahead to find a point
towards which one can practically work
how do you influence people now by
understanding policy so if you get them
to do the right thing and I think the
best way to influence people is to get
them to see things and whether it's
create market visibility or make them
understand what might be worthy goals
like domestication of biotechnology but
what happens when all those things it's
one thing to create a piece of art that
sort of stays where you put it it's
another to mess around with life oh yes
no that's a question that the whole
point that we are moving into this post
our winni an era when genes are freely
shared just like software it's
essentially open source for genes in the
future they're not going to be species
anymore this is going to be much more
common
it will be a very radical change most
people don't like radical changes but
they happen anyway and so we have laws
about what kinds of animals you can make
and what to you can't I mean it's gonna
be regulated just like everything else
yes some wisdom in making the rules do
you have any initial ideas of what might
be some useful rules well how can you do
it better seriously no I think I can do
it better but I mean there will have to
be of course involvement of the public
involvement of the legal profession
involvement of the politicians decisions
made by whole societies rather than just
by individual yeah but you're now a
member of some Commission and what are
you going to suggest as a starting point
for the kinds of rules that would be
appropriate
I'm not a member of any Commission you
know I'm
I'm putting you on this commission I
leave that to you I know I have great
respect for people on commissions with
well I am on a committee of the National
Academy of Sciences which is supposed to
examine this problem of how you deal
with biotech bio technological hazards
and of course we can all see that the
future is dark with hazards and in
particular biological weapons which have
been around for 50 or 60 years so that
nothing terribly new in that with the
help of modern technology you could
imagine even has been don't lower your
cage no I mean it is clear that it's a
good idea for the international
community to worry about what can be
done with microbes microbes are much
more dangerous than orchids and roses
and even more dangerous than lizards and
snakes so it is microbes we really have
to concern ourselves with and you have
certainly the rules should be written so
that kids can play around with dinosaurs
if they feel like they shouldn't play
around with viruses
you were way in the thick of the Cold
War and what led up to the Cold War a
nuclear confrontation and those are
pretty dark times do you think the
hazard is greater or less now than we
faced in say the 1950s certainly less I
mean there was a real danger in the
nineteen fifties that we could have
pretty much wiped ourselves out I don't
see that as a danger at the present time
the dangerous we have now are much more
gradual and more long-range but
certainly we lived through some real
desperately dangerous times in the
fifties and sixties well that gives me a
lot of courage for the future and we
lived in some pretty lives through a lot
of very bad times in the thirties and
forties those of us who survived here
comes the question
this is from Peru Schwartz reading what
are your views I think alas this on all
of you what are your views on climate
change and whether nuclear power should
be a response to the threat of climate
change Freeman yeah well I'm in the
category of skeptics about what's
generally called global warming I mean
the phrase climate change of course it's
perfectly acceptable and it has a real
meaning and if that's what's really
happening is changing but the phrase
global warming is sort of misleading
because it so tries to reduce everything
to a single number really the average
temperature this is really all that
significant what's significant is how
much it rains and how many hurricanes we
have understanding of the problem that's
good enough to take any substantial
actions at the present time so in that
sense I'm a skeptic I believe that it's
an embarrassing situation to be in that
I happen to agree with George Bush about
this question even though I disagree
with him about almost everything else we
simply don't know enough about climate
change to try to try to influence it one
way or the other we shall be changing
the
and we ought to be careful to change it
in the sensible way and I think we shall
doubt how to do that yes sir there too I
agree with all that there are two other
things to add one is the challenge of
changing the climate is there's no way
to make it better for everybody
and so inaction is much easier or at
least not willful acknowledge because
you're always gonna end up making
somebody colder who's already cold or
somebody even warmer that's already home
enough
the second thing to say is clearly I
don't know that climate change I do know
that pollution and you just need to fly
into any urban area and look at the
disgusting thing you're wanting into a
seal and that Brown to know that plain
old poo should forget about what it does
to the climate is genuinely a problem
and I'm a big fan of careful nuclear
what's more interesting than it is
what's going to happen and in all the
developing markets if we could only stop
them including mass transit that really
worked before they get this notion of
everybody should have his own car do it
do it
but there are a lot of car sharing and
ride-sharing schemes I think that would
work if you introduce them in a world
where people don't have cars and oh gee
I could have a quarter of the car is a
very nice proposition but if you start
with a whole car I should point out that
s3 doesn't drive she lives in Manhattan
so it's easy for me to say this famously
the greenest city and probably the world
because of the density and it's a large
part of her social life comes from
catching rides for the people George do
you have an opinion on this one yeah add
something there I have a theory that we
went but nothing wanted those first
eighteen computers what he really wanted
them for was was weather control he
believed that was the project but the
bombs were the immediate need but then
they were going to be used for for
understanding and then controlling the
weather and everyone thinks that was as
crazy as only a meeting eighteen
computers and I think in the end we're
going to get there and we're not even
going to know it we're gonna have real
serious climate control and and nobody
will really notice that it happened the
way that's going to happen is that as
you see what's happening with the price
of oil
more and more we're gonna go to win and
we're gonna go to solar and other
sources of environmental power and if
you're gonna run the grid on wind power
you need to be very well connected to
weather prediction to know it's going to
be windy in Tennessee but it's going to
be calm in Ohio so we're gonna move the
power this way that was gonna be sunny
here say there and how are we going to
do that
very large
and who will be the human being who
actually knows when that system actually
starts changing things rather than just
taking advantage of what's there and and
all the only individuals will be part of
that grid it won't just be the power
companies but people will have software
that will enable them to sell and buy
power in the market usually not knowing
much but it will be done locally George
I have a question for you this is a
biotech question Friedman sauce sort of
talking about let's just have a trees
that engineer them so there's a tap on
the side the gasoline comes out of it
and you've been living in a tree on and
off for a while yes and so my question
is presuming to do that because you like
it aesthetically and for other reason
are you looking forward to buildings
being made of living tissue biotech
buildings that oh I've been responding
metabolize and things like that yeah I
think it's a great idea because there's
a coral reef is a great example of that
if the whole city functioning a living
organism the one thing that's missing in
my there's a number of things abala g
just hasn't done because biology moves
incrementally it can't make the leap one
of those trees in the ocean we have kelp
but it's a it doesn't have a vascular
system but I possible have vascular
plants that really went from the deep
sea floor where there's lots of
nutrients to the surface where there's
lots of sunlight but nothing just
but you put it's a big leap you can't do
it I could make a big difference if we
are able to breed trees with silicon
leaves we know that silicon could
convert to electricity with we could
figure out right the genius for a plan
to make silicon leaves it could be ten
times as efficient as existing plants in
turning sunlight into fuel so it would
mean that solar energy could be
generated on one tenth of the land that
it takes for tomorrow that would make a
huge difference in fact that's the
problem which I think will be solved
I don't trust any of my own
prognostications I'd like to tell a
little story about one of the great
predictions that I made which was a long
time ago when I had a conversation with
Francis Crick and that was in the year
1945 at the end of the World War two
and Francis Crick was then the physicist
who had been working for the British
Royal Navy for about six years and was
totally depressed and discouraged he
said I will never amount to anything as
a scientist he said I was trained as a
physicist but I'd forgotten everything
I've been working for the Navy for six
years and I don't know what I'm going to
do after the war it's not I'm just too
old to do anything useful and so I tried
to encourage him a bit then about a year
of they died I happened to meet the
began he said oh I decided what I going
to do I'm going to make a fresh start
I'm going to do biology and I said but
that's all wrong said it's true that in
the long run biology is going to be the
most interesting science but that would
be too late for you
by the time biology really comes of age
you'll be too old
so anyway of course it only took him
seven years to prove me wrong freedom
that's even paying attention for about
78 years now to pace of change and what
you just described is the kind of thing
that rake routes while was talking to
this audience about we can have to go
that things are coming faster and faster
now partly is we get older things come
faster anyway
but you get a sense that things are
coming faster and faster and so when
you're making these remarks about
silicon trees and so on you expect to
see that in the next decade or the next
century so I think it's the most
difficult thing is to know the time
scale in which things happen I mean
because from diamond-- thought he could
control the weather in ten years and of
course it took a lot longer than that
but it's never going to happen at all it
will be a more like a hundred year so
you just never know how quick how
difficult or how easy things are going
to be in the case of the I would say 50
would be a reasonable guess but I could
be wrong by a factor of five either way
you title this the difficulty of looking
far ahead a little more about that
we're still talking about
are we tapering off then is this a sort
of a leveling population just pursue
this a little further
what's your scale of future useful to
think about well first I actually think
there has been a huge change between
when I was a kid in people's assumptions
about communication in when I was
growing up most things you couldn't know
you could you could find them that
remotely over time when I started
working at Forbes magazine when I wanted
to find stuff out I would go to the
library or I could find a phone
directory call a company and two or
three days later in the nails
now any seven-year-old knows that he can
send an email to somebody in Japan
there's the amount of information that's
available in real time everywhere to me
is it's the biggest change that's
happened and children's assumptions in
in your grandmother's day children
children of well-to-do families were
kept in a completely separate world then
in North yes sir
whatever yes when when I was growing up
if you had been careless enough to let
me watch TV I I could have seen the
adult world or something that passed for
it but I still was treated as a child
now children are completely part of the
adult world even at 14 year olds running
little businesses and going online and
those changes which are partly social to
me are huge the change that I see coming
has something to do with genetic
engineering and if you like the
perfectibility of humans and I use that
word perfectibility advisedly but if you
spend time in Eastern Europe then you
look at the people they have worse they
they have wrinkles there and you come to
the US people seem plastic already and I
think that's going to be the biggest
change I don't know what it means but in
in the past you kind of you got your
body you got your brain and that's what
you were stuck with but in the future if
you if you get older you get sick or you
get stupid or ugly it's going to be
considered your responsibility and you
know he's so careless he didn't care to
fix himself it's
I think it's gonna be a very interesting
and very socially joining change no but
I predict it George the other view on
this
this one's from Tim Bishop waving hand
there he is right there
this question is there's gonna be for
all of you in your own way each of you
are utopians what have you learned from
your collisions with the law of
unintended consequences whoever has the
first one that leaps to mind
I never expected to predict anything we
have intended consequences with the wall
I wouldn't say where they if you see it
most strongly in biology and technology
just things these get developed for one
reason then they are cases with
computing or you know what happened in
biology with crystallography being being
done for one reason and suddenly it
changes one of the striking examples of
cautiously spread diseases
the the other unintended it's not
exactly an unintended consequence but
there's a certain carelessness that you
can see in Iraq which failed to learn
from Afghanistan which failed to learn
from the Soviet Union which is if you
you get rid of the bad guys at the top
you don't really fix the problem and
it's it's it's a failure of the
leadership which every leadership in
whatever place and it happens again and
again to misunderstand the how
deep-rooted most situations or
conditions are so it's an undated
you get rid of a disease with some drug
and then you discover you creative new
drug resistant varieties you get rid of
a dictator and you find out that there's
eight people worse ready to take this
place so if you know at the same time it
doesn't mean don't do anything there's
there's a real shortage of people who
are willing to make mistakes in order to
do something that's clearly good even
though
as you see this now in the drug industry
we're in order to stop ten people having
heart attacks you deny hundreds of
people the pain relief or they don't
think diet can three hundred people may
die of cancer so that two people don't
die of heart attacks because the two
heart attacks were caused by a drug
where is the cancer in your coats is
natural these are the kinds of things
where you need people willing to make
mistakes and to cause harm in order to
cause greater good
just as you also need people understand
I think we were this your answer is big
the question in the interesting way
condition yes I think these are not
utopias and in fact I would suggest
there's a spectrum between faith-based
actions and thinking over which
unintended consequences of the norm
over to evidence-based which these guys
live in the various forms focusing on
business focusing on engineering and
research focusing on science and the
middle is notion based and notion based
is the kind of thing that led us down a
blind alley and in Iraq I think there
was a notion that certain things that
occur to you just describe it's not
really faith it's just when you really
are
pull the notion strongly you develop a
very selective blindness about data it
doesn't agree with that notion and the
idea being evidence-based is you develop
a selective interest and that doesn't
fit with your notion and that's how I
mean it's behavior works and that's
where I think these guys are in that
light Jill tarter has a question it's
right over here
city is a wonderful evidence free
suppose we can assure ourselves that
there aren't any indigenous Martians or
your opens or asteroid
what are the pros and cons of taking
terrestrial life to solar system bodies
beyond Earth have you seen the pictures
of Hyperion they're absolutely
incredible it's hard to believe there
isn't somebody there it's full of
caverns it looks like it's very light in
it's got all these holes in it smaller
not very small moons of Saturn they
turns out to look like a sponge and it's
quite quite absolutely weird anyhow that
wasn't answering the question do you
think we should be heading out - well it
sounds tell me your questions sort of
suggest that if there are creatures out
there we should not get out but so far
you haven't found creatures so so far
that's not an issue and we can head out
and you favor it I take we're gonna make
the Dyson Sphere around our solar system
ya know I think it's very important if
we want to monkey around with human
nature which is then we really will need
more space this planet is too small
so I think that that to be the most
urgent reason for wanting to go
somewhere else to do such experiments I
think we should definitely and if you
want to back me around with human nature
go somewhere else
you guys have views on this say very
simply more space we like to explore
let's go but it ought to be cheap so
that it's available to everybody all I
see is a you know it's not clear we will
recognize
by the way less than George was here he
gave to me the most definitive futurist
statement I've heard that is he gave
this wonderful history he's a historian
of how the computer technology came
along and changed the world and the many
amazing works that happened along the
way and someone asked a question toward
the end what about the future of
computer technology and applause
longtime city future just wait and see
here's kind of a mathematical question
from looks like Dave Yaga Dumont all
right close Stephen Wolfram and Rudy
Rucker suggests that the universe is a
set of gnarly computations being carried
out and often these computations are
irreducible there's no shortcuts could
this be the main reason it is difficult
to look far ahead go to some extent that
is true but I think you think the you
know a number of theories going around
now that fredkin and so on the universe
is sort of basically information
well the metaphorical statement here's
question from devala handling
what won't change and your pursuit when
you preferred far ahead time frame
that's a good one for Georgian
conservative in this group I mean I
think human nature won't change for a
very long time NC will change but it's
been remarkable ecstatic like ours we
all evolved living in a small family
group in the village we're talking to
twelve people we knew thirty people for
even that's exactly what you all have on
yourself which is twelve people you will
answer for in this video thirty people
in your address book fifty that recall
we just revert to these we use the new
technology to revert to our old self I
think that's a very powerful force it
will keep us well I would have said
human nature pardon
I missed it but I would have said human
nature but it's it's kind of interesting
if human nature is I believe
fundamentally the result of evolution
and if we which I believe is how we got
here just to make that clear what's
amazing is that that's an applause well
yeah but if we and human nature is
things like greed and hunger and desire
for a claim and some some desire for
closeness and intimacy and affiliation
and jealousy and all these kinds of
things that make people strive to do
stuff and if we do something closer to
intelligent design to make everybody
nicer and more placid and intelligent
the human nature is going to change and
I'm I think that's the biggest and the
scariest experiment well it's all right
if we they go away and do it somewhere
else
like Australia yeah that works for a
hundred years but it's interesting to
speculate how if you if you created some
kind of new race and you stuck them all
on Mars what would happen if you came
back 100 years later the essence of all
these interactions is that you can't the
guys in Australia they were stuck with
one another and the people on Mars
whatever they might be will be stuck
with one of them it will be interesting
to see how that I'm not sure it's an
experiment we all tend to take but it
would be interesting to see how that ya
know I'd like to do it with a much
larger number of different places which
we have you could have separate
societies you just have to have some
sort of rules that they weren't allowed
to interfere with each other beyond just
friendly social communication and then
the meanest ones would win that would
have to be some sort of regulation
that's clear but yours are frustrated
question from Brad Neuberg
how the heck can we get off the planet
what lessons have we learned from the
failure of the Space Age and by the way
Oh Ryan never got pretty far off the
ground
now there's big talk about houki do
we're gonna go back to the moon was it
40 years later no well this of course
was almost entirely a problem with
politics
political force driving the moon
operations in the 1960s was entirely
just it was an international sporting
event that's what it is today or the
trouble is we don't have a competitor so
I hope that the Chinese will play off I
think maybe the way to do it is in fact
the privatization and commercialization
of space travel and as I said earlier I
actually try and make certain things
happen what happened when you took the
internet from DARPA and turned it into a
commercial operation Unleashed huge
amounts of energy money funding
creativity focus experiments and in the
end success and I think the same thing
would happen with space travel there's a
company I'm actually an investor in
called space adventures which they they
were the guys who got Dennis Tito and
Mark Shuttleworth up in the space and 20
million for them 1 million in a few
years perhaps and if space travel I
think is going to be vulgar and
commercial and tacky full of cotton
candy they're going to put logos on the
Rockets and that's how we're gonna get
there we're going to excite people's
imaginations not just by beating the
Russians the fight you could be there to
know that's absolutely right but it will
take a little longer I think than most
of these
one of the things about families is
there's a lot of conversation that goes
on and a lot of is just reviewing the
various who's on first stuff within the
family and some what is kind of catching
up and so on but you guys have probably
exchanged opinions on a number of things
over the years there any that you find
you disagree on an interesting way I'm
trying to get a little flight Kevin
Kelley urged me to do that well with
deference to Peter Schwartz I I just
I've not been won over for nuclear power
yet I'm still not in the best of all
possible in the real world nuclear power
as a commercial is this the first time
you guys have talked about it or he oh
yes we've talked around it and that's
that's one of many many technologies are
you sanguine about the other
technologies that Bremen is comfortable
with that's that's one of the few but
that's but that's gonna be one of your
obsessions with what I'm actually going
to I think what you really want is
touching family anecdotes so I'm going
to tell one the the three of us have
never been up here up on any stage
together but Freeman and I were a few
years ago I think we were getting
honorary degrees at Clarkson University
or so right and I got up there and I
gave sort of the typical internet
erosion of power and Carman of the
individual speech whatever
Freeman got up there and did something
very courageous that gave even me the
creeps which was somebody you'll
remember this much better than that you
may want to just take this away but some
somebody you know slightly have been
accused of pedophilia and pedophilia is
is worse than murder it's it's you know
it's it's the one sin that even to be
accused of means you cannot be defended
and Freeman defended this guy not for
pedophilia but for don't accuse this guy
with that and he got a kind of I think
shocked and sort of well I guess he's
Freeman Dyson so we respect what he said
he had the courage to do this
yeah that was Kelton guide ASEC who is
one of my heroes he's a great dessert
he's a would a wonderful anthropologist
who has won a Nobel Prize for finding
the cause of this neurological disease
called kuru which was decimating
populations in the Solomon Islands and
then he adopted 60 of these kids who had
been orphaned by the disease brought
them to the United States paid for their
upkeep and educated them and when I mean
that's a long and complicated story he
has essentially had his name blackened
by two of the kids who were I think
they've made of I mean most of his kids
in fact turned out very well and made
successes of their lives truthin did not
come so they were just just depressed
and disgruntled and they blame Carlton
for having them anyway they got into the
hands of some clever lawyers and accused
Carlton of child abuse and as I said the
label it was like being called a
communist in the 1950s you really want
to damage some of the you call
hence Department in fact as a result of
this is he was sent to jail for a year
and I went to welcome him when he came
out of jail together with four or five
of his kids who came along too and we
had a wonderful party to celebrate and
then he went and since then he's been
living in Europe a lot of the time in
China he's welcome everywhere in the
world except in the United States so
that's the story I don't claim any
particular credit for having defended
him I think it was just common sense
here's the question converge
pensee will we be able to increase
animal species intelligence toward human
intelligence through biotech engineers
and hearing and do we want to that's the
implied rest of the question yes we love
our pets and we love it when they love
us back and we probably
there's a wonderful story about this
years ago
you're in agreement and there was no
intelligence for animals I was once in
Japan long long ago as a reporter for
Forbes and I had a respectable role to
play and I was having dinner with this
guy from Hitachi who ran the hardware
division or something and I was asking
all these questions about Hitachi and
its strategy and software and so forth
and he he wasn't really answering then
finally he just stopped talking and
giggled and looked at me and said so
funny to hear woman ask these questions
I felt like a talking cat it was so that
was exactly what the artist sirota
said she was the lady who wrote the
Japanese Constitution when she was I
think 22 years old she went to Japan
with MacArthur's staff and she was the
only person on MacArthur staff who was
really bilingual and bicultural she had
grown up in Japan and so she really knew
the culture so she actually got to write
the Japanese Constitution and she got to
negotiate and she said she has a huge
advantage when she was negotiating
because they'd never had to deal with a
young woman of 22 which was something
totally out of their experience that she
always got what she wanted
so the first intelligent animals will
have these kinds of advantages and and
problems because nobody will take them
seriously well Freeman you mentioned
science fiction a couple times in by the
way the author of that story is all that
staple that I should say more about Olaf
Stabler there's the IQ just you did an
introduction for his book or something
the Star Maker I guess it was and you've
written science fiction as we saw in the
introduction evidently you've read a lot
of science fiction
it's the role science fiction in all of
us oh it's huge
radical out-of-the-box ideas come first
out of science fiction
do you read contemporary science fiction
or adopt full George you read science
fiction also not enough I mean I used to
read all of stapled it all okay all
everything Olaf Stapledon the road I'm
all collected all his he actually wrote
to you know his ultimate bad case
scenario for you for us was something
that's happening micro processors and
they what they came from Mars but
doesn't matter where they came from Mars
or from and they infiltrated everything
last in first Mendes where that is not
enough the one thing I actually would
suggest is getting me all Stevenson down
here that was amazing
nobody gets Neil Stevenson to talking to
you because one point he made was that
at least for him science fiction was
turning into historical fiction and he
wasn't quite sure why but I think if you
pressed him you'd get a very interesting
talk yeah he's one you have to interview
like you did at one of your conferences
I got him through George what are you
reading now George I'm gonna go down the
line I want to know what about reading
anything I essentially read non
nonfiction I'm actually reading Ray
Kurzweil read primary-source die
papers left behind by forgotten stuff
see a little bit about the relation of
primary source documents to the story
that gradually becomes told is your
unique and you really go back and sort
of undo the the common story by looking
at the resources what's that process
about it it's about detail and it's
about remember remembering things is
very different from what really really
happened
I've been Freeman let me copy all his
letters
suppose all of the email that all of us
are writing instead of disappearing like
everything digital was going to be
actually his capital is that it before
roosters right here you not only kept
that accessible the world becomes google
eyes and brewster eyes and and all the
email is is forever searchable by
anybody for free what happens to stories
when we all can see the the primary
documents I think it's a good thing I
mean I was on this life thanks to again
I think thanks to you and Peter on this
Library of Congress mini Commission
originally looking at that problem and I
think it's great that we're gonna saving
everything is one solution and then then
it becomes a search problem how do you
search it later and the the DNA people
are teaching us how to do that from this
incredible number of fragments just all
the fragment and disk drugs in the world
you can you can reconstruct everything
at some future time and then future
people like dead hard drives and
actually it becomes not a search problem
but a filtering problem and then it
requires someone like you to make a
narrative any coherence right that's
knowing what to search for that's
interesting that it's documentary film
some sort of taking off in the last two
or three years and part of it is because
it's so easy to record things a lot of
people are putting them together into
two stories which are now fighting it
out at the box office with no special
effects in fiction maybe that's a trend
what are you reading these days well I'm
reading they all laughed at Christopher
Columbus which is more or less factual
biography
he's a delightful fellow he's now I
think he's gone bankrupt six times he
never loses hope he's one of my heroes
it's a great guy it's not a great book
but it's certainly worth reading my
computer like like George I read
original source documents but minor
minor current and perspective so it's
it's business plans it's my basic
assumption if it's being written down
why should I write it again so I talked
to people about what their businesses
are supposed to do and try and figure
that out
figure out whether they're credible and
most what I really is actually email and
attachments you know it's very sad no
it's not sad it's a lot of fun but I I
wish I could live a parallel life and
read novels
okay Freeman is a parallel life
something that'll be accessible pretty
soon it's possible I mean I think we
have we certainly will as I see the
future now I'm going to start talking
nonsense but bitten as I see the futures
the next hundred years will belong to
biotechnology
the molecular sense of of getting real
mastery of how to write the software of
genomes so we can produce any kind of
creatures to perform any sort of
functions we find either beautiful or
desirable or even useful the hundred
years after that I would say belong to
neurology and that's when all kinds of
totally different kinds of problems
arise of course when you start monkeying
around with the human soul and that's
when you start talking about parallel
lives there's no reason I can see why
you shouldn't have some kind of
dissociated personalities to give you
the chance of living six or seven lives
which otherwise you'd have to choose
between I would love to have seven
alternatives for living my life I'd have
done all sorts of other things so that's
to me that's certainly a very big big
and positive something to look forward
to but again it's going to require more
space we come back to this question I
would say about Esther was saying that
these societies in the remote parts of
the solar system will start to be at
each other's throats I don't think that
that's necessarily so if you go far
enough away and you can go far enough
away you can get away
with the paralyzes you don't you don't
get any satisfaction from them unless
you somehow reintegrate them at the end
otherwise we just have one person
turning into seven well they can talk to
each other these people yeah oh well
okay if I'm writing a science fiction
novel the novel I want to write is it's
sort of the jonbenet ramsey novel it's
the story of a person and his
relationship with his child clone the
the relationship between a parent and a
child is always fraught with some
tension because the child the parent
lives through the child imagine what
that's like
if the child is actually the clone of
the parent I think would make a great
novel okay I'm gonna have a question in
a minute for Freeman to see if you have
any questions for these guys it means
that last question from the audience
this is from Kevin Kelly says in your
years of looking ahead what have you
changed your mind
yes sir you've been spelling off the
release 1.0 you're always pushing what's
just about to happen along the way if
they're dings and like serious mind
changes what's actually going on if you
have any changes about it the only big
change and this is the real one that I
kind of signaled at the beginning is
moving from trying to understand what's
going on to try to influence it much
more actively which in the end this is
far more satisfying even if you don't
succeed it's like what's the point of
holding a conference unless people go do
something different afterwards than they
would have done if you hadn't done it
and that's certainly what motivates
people to write books and and make
scientific discoveries some have to
change the world not simply to predict
it does suggest that all predictions are
there hope forward through the fall in
some respect or order no or more
normative this is how it ought to be and
if you'd only see it my way you'd do the
right things to make it happen this way
that's kind of my my subtext so there's
no such thing as an objective prediction
really and I don't think there should be
there should they should not be false or
deceptive but if you go in and you're
negotiating with something
tell them this is what I want you to do
and here's my understanding of the
situation and my motivations and that's
actually very persuasive especially if
it's also to their benefit but you you
don't undercut your argument by making
it transparent otherwise you're
manipulative and deceitful that you can
the best arguments are honest and
transparent and true but they're there
with an agenda no III I was just
thinking about my own experience I mean
III certainly misjudged several
historical events that came out of the
shadows and became public all the
essential information about nuclear
reactors was Declassified in 1955 who
was then free for everybody to move in
and try to do something so I went there
to general atomic in California and work
for the company to build nuclear
reactors and we all believed at that
time this was the wave of the future
which of course it wasn't and so it's
easy to be mistaken about things of that
kind I don't regret it because we had a
lot of fun we did some good work and in
the long run we probably were right son
somehow or other it's going to come back
it's going to be useful but the hardest
thing to foresee is how long it's going
to take we thought it would take 10 or
20 years
then those the same thing again happened
with the spacecraft was a spaceship that
George was talking about we thought we
had this wonderful nuclear spaceship we
would actually expected ourselves to go
out and explore Saturn would have been
wonderful if we'd seen that picture of
Hyperion that we solved this last week
actually with our own eyes anyway we
missed that opportunity but I don't
regret that either it's the hardest
thing is to foresee how long I think how
long things are going to take and that's
of course true in space when we talk
about the human nature it's obvious that
human nature is going to change